auf der documenta in kassel hat es einen
krassen fall von antisemitismus gegeben
und 0 konsequenzen ganz im gegenteil
kulturstaatsministerin claudia roth und
documenta chefin sabine schormann die
streiten sich auf offener bühne und
keiner will die verantwortung tragen und
genau darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit
unserer chefreporterin antonia jamin
antonia schön dass du da bist erklär uns
auf was genau ist da passiert also das
passiert erstmal vor vier wochen das ist
diese documenta kunstausstellung und da
geht es um ein gemälde an die milde dass
eine indonesische kunstgruppe malt sehr
viele verschiedene objekte allerdings da
gibt es zwei objekte die einfach
antisemitismus schreien vielleicht
können wir das sehen ein objekt war
wirklich von einem user mit so dracula
10 und so ss runen auf dem kopf das
andere objekt oder die andere karikatur
da geht es um ein israelischer soldat
mit einem davidstern und ein schweine
gesicht und oben auf dem hang steht
mossad mossad ist der geheimdienst von
israel sehr viele
verschwörungstheoretiker auf der ganzen
welt kritisiert natürlich den mossad
sehr oft und das passiert hier in
deutschland wir sehen gerade die sturm
also wie gesagt das sind karikaturen die
uns wirklich an den ns zeit
erinnern und das passiert offen in
deutschland in eine sehr große
prominente
kunstveranstaltung vor vier wochen
natürlich große skandal mann wurde
danach hat man auch das gemälde
abgedeckt aber wie ihr gesagt hat bis
jetzt noch keine verantwortung das ist
wirklich unglaublich man fragt sich wie
kann es eigentlich sein dass so ein
bilder ausgestellt wird aber du sagst es
selbst vor vier wochen passiert was ist
jetzt aktuell passiert was gibt's neues
also jetzt stellt es sich heraus dass 90
mitarbeiter dieser documenta
kunstausstellung
bds anhänger sinn oder bds freunde sind
bds ist die boykott moment gegen israel
und palästina sehr viele leute auf der
welt meinen auch dass es auch mit
antisemitismus zu tun hat antizionismus
ist sehr oft auch antisemitismus
der zentralrat der juden hat seit januar
schon gewarnt hinter den kulissen und
auch öffentlich dass es in dieser
ausstellung zu antisemitismus kommen
könnte wir haben auch mit der ministerin
darüber gesprochen und die meinte nein
ich werde nichts gegen der kunst machen
kunstfreiheit und so weiter und so
weiter
und jetzt wie gesagt ein streit zwischen
der documenta chefin und die
kulturministerin claudia roth documenta
chefin meint dass die ministerin ihr
empfohlen hat mit einer bds anhängerin
also moment gegen israel mitzuarbeiten
claudia roth die ministerin sagt habe
ich nicht gemacht es ist eine lüge jetzt
ein wort gegen es andere und wenn ihr
mich fragt beide mussten gehen weil fakt
ist dass seit januar der zentralrat der
juden mit denen gesprochen hat hat sie
davon gewarnt in der voll und die
documenta chefin die hat diese künstler
begleitet sie wusste ja was sie da
hinstellt und wenn sie nicht selber
gesehen hat dass das antisemiten
antisemitismus ist ist sie einfach blind
und die ministerin also sorry man kann
man kann einfach nicht die verantwortung
jemand anderes geben und sagen
man hat mich gewarnt man hat mich
gewarnt aber ich habe nichts gemacht
antonia mit der bitte um kurze antwort
wie fühlt sich das ganze für dich als
jüdin an ich werde hier nicht sagen dass
es beschämend ist weil das ist was
deutsche politiker sagen immer wenn so
was in deutschland passiert ich werde
aber doch sagen dass ich mich als
deutsche und als juden schäme wenn mich
meine israelische freunde oder
israelische journalisten anrufen und
mich fragen sag mal was passiert denn in
deutschland weil 80 jahre nach dem
holocaust zeigt man in deutschland
öffentlich solche karikaturen die mich
an goebbels propaganda erinnern und wie
gesagt keine verantwortung keine
verantwortung und alle sitzen noch sehr
brav bei ihrem job wir sind sehr
gespannt ob der eine oder andere noch
seine konsequenzen daraus ziehen wird
antonia jamin besten dank für dein
besucher tv st